Brady Shay interrupted by Yanni gourd
here come the Kraken through Center
gourd unattainable for hel tolvanen
but he gets there now this way it's
Andre burkovski he'll rethink it
shootting it stepped in Yan Gard
the pepper poot on the spot 1244 left to go
in the opening period Seattle off and running
[Music] it's Andre burkovski that throws it
to the front of the net look at the net front
presence tolven is there Gord is there
two Kraken only one Carolina hurricane
numbers strength and numers JT and the Kraken
is Johnny said off and running again that puck
is going well wide too so a good deflection
in on that and no chance for rovski gets the
only assist slaven tipped in with traffic
out in front Jacob slaven who has a couple
of goals already this season yper fost was
on the doorstep he'll get the goal and we're
tied like for Seattle all with a one or a one
draw for Carolina defense goes down the wall
and it's just a quick face off play throwing
it to the back of the net he's trying to hit
F directly it doesn't go to his stick it ends up
being a bouncer looks like it ends up going off
the skate and in but that is a setup play if
you watch from the start the way fos goes all
the way around the D down the wall they're trying
to hit this back door play getting to those pucks
just a little bit quicker SE needs to do in the
defensive Zone MOS Shu Casino power play Schwarz
scor oh a Nifty little dangle out in front by
Jaden Schwarz it's a power play goal Kraken
by [Music] [Applause] one it's just a set
PL watch this dun gets it Carolina's so
aggressive he bypasses the aggressiveness
of Carolina and he goes forehand backhand
right between the legs beautiful play well
Schwarz had a similar situation where he
had too much time in front this time he
attacks R it went off Francis cheron now
CMI moved along larsson's up and ready 25
seconds left on the kill done a shot kicked
out they score short hand and goal
his first is a kraken Pierre Edward
Belmar for this penalty killing unit so
far this season excellent read by Vince
stun to jump into the play he shoots for
the far pad and Belmar goes the one knee
and buries this Puck short-handed
goal and the cracken with a two-goal
lead well just a perfectly executed play that
penalty killing units got some Swagger oh
there boy they've got it going on burns top of the
crease the cor says no on NAS Nas stopped again by
Joey DOR the Kraken got to be better defensively
here watch this save right here oh what a that's
Dynamite power play and then the Kraken go
to work and Yamamoto did an outstanding job
of getting it to the front of the net after
getting the pass from burkovski Jaden Schwarz
has a power play goal tonight for Seattle Don
with a shoty start right down Lenny Wilkins way
a bullet from from vinston on the Power Play 4
to one Seattle an absolute Dart from Vin stun
what a pass by Andre burkovski and JT the entry
so key on a power play we're able to get in with
some speed kick the puck out done walking right
down in I'm glad he does not hesitate at all on
and off the stick glove side but it does look
like a goalie change is being made here edzo
borgan sees it now dord will sweep it out
to neutral ice intercepted by Jacob slaven
threaded in the zone Alexia off his stick
out in front they score Seth Jarvis on a
change gets the pass as he was set up
by Stephen Mason and Carolina is within
two Mason made a heck of a play he got the
puck Off the Wall got inside the dots and
Jarvis finds that soft little area that pass goes
by three Kraken defenders in their own Zone and no
chance for Joey as he tries to slide left or right
desperation mold while losing a stick 68 seconds
into period three Seth Jarvis to the outside n
fans on it good stick by McAn off the end boards
kokami rubbed out by Lar in a hard way Seth Jarvis
has control deeper it goes for n n has kokami
in front he scores yes cooki on the doorstep
1405 left to go in regulation it's a new ball
game in behind the net n a nice job of protecting
the puck and then Goen Miami find that puck you
see where Joey's looking watch him take a
look over his right shoulder he think he's
going the other way and the puck comes back
this way take it back to the corner and cycle
out Jared mccan turns off the glass in play
poked Along by Bor strand he'll get away from
n to the slot they score Jared mccan hey hey
what do you say 53 Seattle [Applause] [Music]
watch the right part of your screen look at him
he's wide open stick in a great position presents
itself and he just air mails it up and over the
goalie's glove what a shot by mccan the balance
is back scoring balance as tug by NIS they play
on and a penalty will be called they score Ty kin
get a beautiful pass from Maddie veneers the
Kraken by three this was going to go watch
the stick right there there's the penalty but
then mdy bers makes a beautiful play off the
reception from Jordan Everly outstanding passes
you mentioned Johnny from Maddie and who goes
to the net and who's been going to the net all
night long Tai k Taps it in beautiful play moved
along for D'Angelo terrifying on the outside
hurried up by alexc he wants no part of that
bunting now back it goes for D'Angelo here's NIS
he'll take it in NIS now back for D'Angelo NES a
one-time stop they score Seth Jarvis collects
the Loose Change 404 left sixth attacker goal
for Jarvis six for Seattle that's a I don't I
don't know if that ever got to Joey pushed out
by Cami Tony D'Angelo for the Hurricanes for
Jack Drury Drury at his side in the trailer
now kokami has the puck Hof's in his shot
stopped by dor ful out six skaters empty
net situation Bullseye Oliver bjorkstrand
74 [Music] Kraken [Music] [Applause] know
Hard 5 seconds left through the
middle that's Kracken hockey baby
win number one for Dave hexall and
his Club it's a 74 win over Carolina